make america great erkennen den
wahlkampfslogan von donald trump gibt es
mittlerweile in zig verballhornungen
dabei ist der slogan weit mehr als ein
geschickter pr spruch sondern er
spiegelt einen weit verbreiteten
reaktionären zeitgeist das zumindest
sagt mark lilla den ich ganz herzlich im
studio in berlin begrüße er ist
professor für ideengeschichte an der
columbia universität in new york und
schreibt neben seinen büchern unter
anderem für die new york times simons
und für die mz
seine kritik an der identitätspolitik
der demokraten die er nach der wahl
sondern tramper hoch sagte auch bei uns
für hitzige debatten herzlich willkommen
herr li na es folglich hier zu sein
sie sagen es weht ein reaktionärer geist
ich nehme an das sind keine guten
nachrichten nein das sind sehr schlechte
nachrichten denn die grundidee des re
aktionismus ist dass es einen bruch in
der geschichte gegeben hat und
reaktionäre wollen um alles in der welt
in die zeit davor zurück während
revolutionäre zu stark auf die zukunft
fokussieren sind reaktionäre zu sehr mit
der vergangenheit beschäftigt zurzeit
setzt sich also niemand wirklich
vertieft mit unserer gegenwart
auseinander
mit den schwierigkeiten unseres heutigen
lebens und unseren politischen problemen
insbesondere mit jenen einer
globalisierten wirtschaft
da sehe ich eine art flucht wurde
intellektuellen verantwortung
ich möchte gerne besser verstehen was
dieser reaktionäre zeitgeist in ist die
sagen es gibt verschiedene beispiel im
moment für reaktionäre ideen wir finden
sie zb ganz froh national aber auch beim
islamischen staat
das sind ja sehr unterschiedliche sagen
wir mal denkrichtungen erstmal was
verbindet den reaktionäre denkst sie
haben dieselbe auffassung von geschichte
zuerst einmal denken sie von der
geschichte her über politik nach nicht
ausgehend vom menschen an sich
und ihrer sicht der geschichte gab es
eine periode in der sich die dinge auf
eine gesunde weise entwickelten bis es
zu einem bruch kam einem moment in dem
alles auseinander brach und alles was
danach passierte war die folge dieses
buchs für den fonds national begannen
die probleme
so wie sie die geschichte jetzt deuten
mit der emigration die migration und die
kulturelle revolution in den 1960 er
jahren führten zur kriminalität
problemen an den schulen und viele mehr
dieser bruch führte also zu all diesen
problemen die uns zwingen
zurückzublicken auf die welt wie sie vor
diesem bruch war für den islamischen
staat sind die dinge ähnlich
anders als seriöse islamwissenschaftler
denken islamisten das im neunzehnten
jahrhundert eine durchgehende islamische
tradition durch die modernisierung und
den kolonialismus zerstört wurde die
aufklärung weckte zudem in den ländern
das bedürfnis sich zu entwickeln und die
modernen wissenschaften etablierten sich
alle heutigen probleme in muslimischen
gesellschaften gehen für die islamisten
darauf zurück dass man von der scharia
abrückte und westliche einflüsse zuließ
sagen sie eigentlich schon sehr klar es
geht darum dass noch nicht eine
entwicklung der geschichte sieht sondern
dass es um diesen bruch geht im moment
ist gerade ihr buch neu auf dem markt
der clowns der vergangenheit da geht es
um diesen reaktionären zeitgeist
erschienen im mtz verlag und da sagen
sie auch oft tauschen uns darüber auch
der reaktionäre eigentlich ist wie
meinen nämlich das sei die cholerische
variante des konservativen aber das habe
ich gar nichts zu tun mit konservativ
sein das müssen sie mir erklären
ich denke man muss sich zwei
gegensätzliche paare
vor augen halten nehmen wir die
konservativen und jene die wir in den
usa liberalen nennen die ihn etwa
eisigen sozialdemokraten entsprechen was
konservative und liberale trend sind
verschiedene ansichten über die
menschliche natur und die beziehung der
individuen zu gesellschaft konservative
sehen die gesellschaft als etwas das
sich kontinuierlich über die zeit hinweg
entwickelt für sie sind wir individuell
viel eher produkte unsere gesellschaft
nicht unabhängige einzelpersonen gesunde
soziale veränderungen sind die folge
davon dass wir diesen individuen
traditionen vermitteln
und wenn es zu veränderungen kommt
ereignen sich diese kontinuierlich und
langsam liberale setzen beim individuum
an und sehen dieses zuerst einmal als
träger von rechten die gesellschaft ist
für sie das produkt eines vertrags
zwischen personen die aus diesem grund
zusammengekommen sind
keine der beiden positionen implizieren
irgend eine historische katastrophe
einen bruch es sind einfach
unterschiedliche ansichten darüber was
uns als menschen individuell und
kollektiv aus
die revolutionäre und die reaktionäre
haltung das zweite gegensätzliche paar
entwickelten sich beide im neunzehnten
jahrhundert
was sie verbindet ist wie gesagt dass es
in ihrer interpretation der geschichte
einen bruch gegeben hat oder dass es zu
einem bruch kommen wird der revolutionär
glaubt dass gewisse politische
aktivitäten einen bruch herbeiführen
werden und danach alles gut sein wird
sollte die revolution bereits erfolgt
sein muss sie weitergeführt werden und
es gilt auch diejenigen zu überzeugen
die bisher nicht mitmachen
er ist von 1980
warum hat er diesen wahlspruch wieder
genommen oder er sagt er hätte ihn gar
nicht wieder genommen hat ihn erfunden
aber es ist interessant dass sie das
einbringen
außerhalb der usa ist das kaum bekannt
ich denke die beiden wollten damit nicht
das gleiche sagen
reagans botschaft war hoffnungsvoll us
amerikaner sind süchtig nach hoffnungen
sie brauchen eine hoffnungsvolle vision
ihrer zukunft ich glaube reagan meinte
nicht wir sollten in früheren zeiten
zurückkehren sondern vielmehr dass wir
wieder so groß sein werden die früher
wenn wir alles richtig machen um das zu
erreichen müssen ja nicht das rad der
geschichte zurückdrehen
bei trump ist es dagegen die idee einer
rückkehr
er will den schaden beheben der offenbar
angerichtet worden ist gemäss
reaktionären gedankengut hat es nicht
einfach nur einen bruch gegangen es
braucht zudem eine apokalypse um die
dinge wieder in ordnung zu bringen
heiliger sagte nur ein gott kann uns nun
noch retten
reaktionäre glauben dass uns nur eine
apokalypse retten kann
und wenn man mit trump anhängern spricht
auch mit intelligenten und gebildeten
sagen sie oft übereinstimmend wir haben
trump gewählt weil wir die dinge
zertrümmern wollten
aus dieser reaktion spricht eine
apokalyptische was ihm ja auch zeigt
dass die enttäuschung so groß ist und
mir fiel da noch ein anderes buch einer
sich ihr buch gelesen habe nämlich
siegen und baumann der große soziologe
der leider verstorben ist sein letztes
buch ist ja rettung kann ich sagen die
topia genau und es ist eine eine idee
eigentlich thomas morus idee von utopia
500 jahre später ins gegenteil zu
verkehren zu sagen na ja der hat sie
noch diese idee wir können irgendwann
die utopie wir können das goldene
zeitalter noch einmal wieder erlangen
währenddessen heute eigentlich wirklich
diese politische nostalgie ganz groß ist
alles muss zusammenbrechen alles ist am
ende und er sagt ganz deutlich die leute
einfach enttäuscht der nationalstaat hat
nicht diese sicherheit und diesen
wohlstand gebracht den man ihnen
versprochen hat und genau so war doch
ein stück weit auch die analyse jetzt
nach der wahl
ja genau und doch interessant an der
enttäuschung von der sie eben gesprochen
haben ist revolutionäre hoffnungen
können immer enttäuscht werden denn man
hofft dass sich durch eine revolution
dinge verändern
nostalgie hingegen ist unwiderlegbar
denn man kann argumentieren der grund
warum die dinge nicht funktionieren ist
nicht die fehlende revolution sondern
dass er nicht genug weit zurückgegangen
sei die menschen haben ein bild der
vergangenheit weil sie sich bereits
ereignet hat wie sich der revolutionär
die zukunft vorstellt ist jedoch eine
fantasie
daher ist es viel einfacher den leuten
politische nostalgie anstatt zukünftige
utopien zu verkaufen sie haben wohin
verglichen was eigentlich der islamische
staat und for national vielleicht
gemeinsam haben könnten sie legen auch
eine sehr interessante deutung vor der
terror-anschläge in paris und 2015 wo
sie eigentlich sagen auch da sieht man
in der art und weise wie nachher
gesprochen wurde und was die motive auch
waren mit diesem ereignis nachher
umzugehen und das auch politisch zu
instrumentalisieren
wie mit eben politische nostalgie
umgegangen wie er die einen denken
nämlich sie hätten so was verloren wie
den gottesstaat die muslimische
wunderbare über macht und die anderen
denken wir sehen jetzt wirklich dass
frankreich am ende ist frankreich hat
eigentlich alles verloren was es jemals
war
ja ich lebte dort als es passierte und
beobachtete wie sich beides nacheinander
entwickelte
seltsamerweise hat ein buch die größte
wirkung welches diese französische
nostalgie in worte fasste und anheizte
lasst zu mission von houellebecq
es wurde am tag des anschlags auf
charlie hebdo publiziert von da an
entwickelten sich beide phänomene
parallel je besser wir die motive der
attentäter verstanden die sehr
nostalgisch und kaum gebildet waren
desto mehr zustimmung bekam die
reaktionäre rechte die zu erklären
versuchte wie so etwas in frankreich
passieren konnte für mich war diese
parallele entwicklung faszinierend
vielleicht bei mir noch einmal
zurückgehen zu dieser idee dass es diese
brüche nicht geben kann oder dass die
sehnsucht nach dem bruch nach der
apokalypse
sie sagen fehlgeleitet ist das bringt
uns aus politik nicht voran
da fiel mir dann doch der fall der mauer
ein
war das nicht ein bruch in der
geschichte wo wir sagen müssen dass
wahrscheinlich ein positiver bruch also
gibt es nicht brüche von denen wir sagen
müssen die sind jetzt nicht unbedingt
negativ zu bewerten
sicher es ist immer einfach erwartungen
zu schüren nicht nur in der politik auch
im persönlichen leben wir heiraten und
erleben enttäuschungen
wir bekommen kinder aber es passiert
noch etwas anderes wenn man die
geschichte so sieht denn das drama
scheint nicht nur dramatisch man hat
auch keine werkzeuge um es zu
beeinflussen
wenn eine ehe nicht ideal verläuft geht
man zu einem therapeuten oder arbeitet
an der beziehung aber was kann man
unternehmen wenn man im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert lebt und
von diesem bruch in der islamischen
geschichte erfährt der jahrhunderte
zurück liegt da kann man praktisch
nichts machen
daher kommen einem radikale mittel in
den sinn man ist vielleicht sogar bereit
diese auch anzuwenden wenn sich dadurch
nichts ändert
gerät man in einen teufelskreis von
enttäuschung und radikalisierung wie wir
es momentan im islamismus beobachtet
wenn ihr die politik in den usa im
moment analysieren dann kommt man
sozusagen auch bei uns nicht an ihnen
vorbei und nämlich an einem bestimmten
text der auch bei uns sehr viel zu reden
gab nämlich ein gastkommentar in der new
york times wo sie gesagt haben
eigentlich sind die us demokraten dafür
verantwortlich zu machen dass kramp
gewonnen hat und zwar deswegen weil sich
zu weit getrieben haben mit der
sogenannten identitätspolitik also mit
dem schutz und der beförderung quasi von
minderheitenrechten das hat ihnen
ziemlich viel ärger eingebracht oder ja
ja ich wurde im internet zum bösewicht
abgestempelt ich wollte die
aufmerksamkeit auf dieses thema lenken
schuld am missverständnis war unter
anderem dass der untertitel lautet darum
hat hillary clinton die wahl verloren
was sich im artikel nicht geschrieben
hatte aber die identitätspolitik ist
teilweise verantwortlich für 30 jahre
politik der demokraten die nicht auf die
nation und unsere gemeinsamen projekte
fokussierte um zum beispiel den
realismus zu bekämpfen sondern auf die
forderungen sorgen und empfindlichkeiten
spezieller bevölkerungsgruppen deren
empfindlichkeiten und sorgen sind real
aber da die demokraten auf kleine
gruppen anstatt auf die nation als ganze
fokussierten und die nation nicht als
schicksalsgemeinschaft verstanden
verloren sie die wichtigkeit
institutioneller politik in den usa aus
den augen
zugunsten einer politik sozialer
bewegungen
es ist nicht so dass die amerikaner
trump wählten weil man von
identitätspolitik sprach aber durch die
fokussierung auf die identitätspolitik
setzten sich die demokraten und die
liberalen vor allem mit verschiedenen
gruppen und ihren einander konkurrenz
ihren forderungen auseinander und
verloren so die visionäre politik für
alle aus den augen und nicht nur waren
es kleine klientel mit politischen
forderungen wie ich in meinem buch zu
beschreiben versuchte gab es eine
entscheidende veränderung die
identitätspolitik die sicher als
institutionelle politik dieser einzelnen
gruppen verstand entwickelte sich zu
einer politik bei der es um die
identität von individuen gegen sie wurde
zur politik der bedeutung da geht es um
mich um meine identität darum wie ich
mich definiere ich will von der
gesellschaft anerkannt werden und ich
engagiere mich nur in der politik wenn
es um dinge geht die mich als individuum
auch betreffen
dadurch wird es sehr schwierig leute für
ein engagement in einem gemeinsamen
projekt zu begeistern
very hard to the jungle vorkommen
sie haben ja auch das ist eine politik
des nazismus und erwähnen immer wieder
wie wichtig ihnen eigentlich der
ausspruch ist ich glaube das ist in der
antrittsrede von john f kennedy als er
gesagt hat wir müssen die darüber
nachdenken nicht nur was kann der staat
mehr geben soll was kann ich dem staat
geben
das heißt irgendetwas stört sie daran
dass die leute irgendwie primär mit sich
beschäftigt
ja ja so gehört auch dass es in unserem
land kein bier mehr gibt nur noch
verschiedene gruppierungen und wenn wir
von wir sprechen ist das nur eine
verdeckte art um auszudrücken was weiße
leute sagen den amerikanischen
universitäten wird das wort wir nur
ironisch gebraucht als ob so etwas gar
nicht existieren würde
das heißt wenn menschen außerhalb von
liberalen kreisen leiden und hoffen dass
sich die nation zusammenrauft um ihnen
zu helfen bieten ihnen nur die
republikaner
eine vision eine schreckliche vision
dragons vision hielt nicht was sie
versprach aber zumindest hatte er eine
vision des landes welche die menschen
inspiriert doch demokraten kritisieren
die weißen wegen dem was sie den
schwarzen angetan haben und so weiter
das sind wichtige themen für die bildung
für filme für die zivilgesellschaft mit
denen wir rechenschaft über unsere
vergangenheit ablegen
aber politik ist politik man muss anders
denkende überzeugen sich für ein
gemeinsames projekt zu engagieren der
narzissmus ist unglaublich tief
verankert vor allem bei den jungen
sie sind unfähig menschen in den
konservativen gebieten amerikas zu
erreichen und obendrein haben sie nur
verachtung für diese übrigen so kann man
die politik nicht sterben aber alle
diese dinge mit ihnen sprechen sie haben
diesen artikel ja auch ausgebaut seinem
buch wo sie diese these noch einmal
aufnehmen und um vertiefen bevor wir
noch einmal tiefer einsteigen möchte ich
jemanden zu wort kommen lassen der das
anders sieht und der sagte moment malen
identitätspolitik ist enorm wichtig für
unseren ruf am online journalist und
psychologe
wer in einen text über dieses thema
gesprochen hat es brauchte identität um
mich aus der traurigkeit zu retten
die schwulenbewegung postuliert eine
welt in der meine abnormität ein sieg
ist identitätspolitik bewirkt immer
zweierlei menschen stolz zu machen die
ein angeborenes oder charakteristisches
leiden haben
und sie bringt die anderen dazu mit den
leuten nette umzugehen
das sind zwei unterschiedliche bereiche
aber der fortschritt in einem halt im
anderen nach identitätspolitik
anarchistisch seien die leute feiern
einen unterschied in der um seiner
selbst willen
sie reduzieren die welt und
funktionieren in separaten gruppen ohne
empathie füreinander aber richtig
verstanden und richtig angewandt sollte
identitätspolitik unsere vorstellung
davon was menschlich ist erweitern
mitmenschlichkeit
das habe ich noch nie gesehen es sieht
fast wie eine antwort auf mein buch auch
sehr interessant lassen sie es mich so
erklären
in den usa finden zwei revolutionen
gleichzeitig statt einerseits die
politische revolution die von rechts und
unten kommt und populistisch ist
gleichzeitig ist eine kulturelle
revolution im gange
dabei geht es um all die dinge die
andrew solomon folien angesprochen hat
nämlich dass menschen anerkennung und
akzeptanz in der gesellschaft brauchen
die veränderungen allein während meiner
lebenszeit sind außergewöhnlich vor 10
oder 15 jahren nahm niemand
gleichgeschlechtliche ehen ernst das ist
eine gewaltige veränderung in der
gesellschaft weltweit solche
errungenschaften sind gut aber diese
revolution wird von kulturellen eliten
geführt sie kommt nicht von unten und
sie ist nicht demokratisch denn niemand
kann darüber abstimmen
aber hollywood die presse die
bildungsinstitutionen sind sich einig
dass diese neuen werte verbreitet werden
müssen das ist gut
das problem ist wenn alle energie in
diese kulturelle revolution gesteckt
wird kümmert man sich nicht mehr um
reale konkrete macht wenn sie außerdem
nur über solche kulturellen dinge
sprechen und darüber dass diese menschen
ausgegrenzt werden bekommt die
öffentlichkeit von ihrer partei oder
politischen gruppierung den eindruck sie
würden sich nur um diese leute und nicht
um die ganze nation und um menschen
kümmern die nicht zu diesen
gruppierungen gehören
man muss also eine tragische
entscheidung treffen bezüglich energie
und retour wahrscheinlich wirklich viele
ärgert nämlich das ist alles richtig
sich um diese belange zu kümmern zum
beispiel auch toiletten fürs dritte
geschlecht alles wichtig aber es sollte
nicht die priorität haben dies im moment
hat das tut natürlich weh und es stellt
sich die frage sie sagen vielleicht kann
ich das auch noch
wenn ich das auch sehr beeindruckt hat
sie sagen es gibt in west virginia
situation wo wir sehen müssen jeder
zweite hat keine arbeit und jeder vierte
ist abhängig von opiaten und das sind
doch auch die probleme und stattdessen
sprechen wir nur über die toiletten für
das dritte geschlecht gebe ich sie so
korrekt wieder und muss man sich dann
entscheiden für die beiden sorgen
ich denke das stimmt und man muss sich
entscheiden
aber noch wichtiger wenn mir leute die
sich in der identitätspolitik engagieren
diese frage stellen muss ich sie von
folgendem überzeugen wenn sie die
institutionelle politik außer acht
lassen können sie diese gruppen in
unserem bundesstaaten gar nicht schützen
denn im föderalen system der usa sind
viele dinge in staatz gesetzen geregelt
lebt man in einem republikanischen staat
in dem es nicht gesetzlich festgelegt
ist dass transgender personen ihre
eigene toilette haben kann das in
washington niemand ändern
ich gebe ihnen ein konkretes beispiel im
stadtteil war beschloss der gesetzgeber
vor ein paar wochen die abtreibung ab
dem moment zu verbieten ab den der
herzschlag des fötus gehört werden kann
das ist etwa einer sechsten
schwangerschaftswoche also bevor die
meisten frauen merken dass sie schwanger
sind
der staat wendet sich gegen das in der
verfassung unseres landes verankerte
recht auf abteilung dieses gesetz
könnten hillary clinton und der kongress
nicht ändern
man kann es nur ändern wenn man nach
europa geht wenn dort wahlen anstehen
und bürger zu überzeugen versuchen mehr
als 80 prozent der einwohner sind weiß
und fast 80% evangelikal man muss also
einen weg finden um diese leute zu
erreichen damit man die eigenen leute
die in diesem staat leben schützen kann
das ist der punkt immer wieder gehört
hat dass man eben nicht nur die
sozusagen unterdrückten minoritäten
sprechen sollte sondern über diese
vielen vielen leute die einfach anders
denken aber sozusagen eigentlich zur
mehrheit gehören ein stück weit
ja ja
damit möchte ich nichts sagen was zu
viele leute denken nämlich man solle die
aufmerksamkeit von einer gruppe auf eine
andere länge
ich finde die demokraten sollten sich
auf gar keine gruppe konzentrieren
sondern vielmehr ihre vision des landes
präsentieren und da legen nach welchen
prinzipien sie es aufbauen wollen
während der reagan jahre
damit meine ich die zeit von 1980 bis
donald trump lautete das motto je
weniger regierung desto besser dann geht
es der wirtschaft und somit allen wir
gehören alle zu unseren familien und
unsere kirche aber es gibt nicht so
etwas wie staatsbürger thum dass
irgendeine bedeutung hätte dieser vision
stellten die demokraten nichts entgegen
und jetzt müssen sie klar machen was für
ein land sie aufbauen wollen damit sich
die angehörigen dieser gruppen in ihren
prinzipien wiedererkennen und sagen
können das bin ich das nicht sie sind im
moment sehr viel unterwegs mit ihren
buchungen mit dieser these sie kommen
von amsterdam gehen danach jetzt von
berlin aus nach paris später nach rom
haben sie den eindruck dass das
interesse an ihrem buch und an dieser
these damit zu tun habe dass sie in
erster linie verstehen möchten was in
den usa passiert oder sehen sie
parallelen begegnen ihnen ähnliche
phänomene in europa holtzbrinck ist also
sehr interessant
es ist das erste buch das sich über die
usa geschrieben habe und ich hätte nicht
erwartet dass es übersetzt würde
doch es wurde weltweit nicht nur in
europa auch in lateinamerika und asien
übersetzt und deshalb bald in china und
korea publiziert und wie ich entdecke
sind die leute nicht am buch
interessiert weil sie etwas über die usa
erfahren wollen sondern weil sich
heutzutage so viele menschen ängstlich
mit der frage nach der identität
befassen
wer sind wir was bedeutet das wort wir
wenn man auf deutsch sagt wir schaffen
das wer ist wir
angesichts der globalisierung unter
massenbewegungen im internet wissen die
menschen nicht mehr was es heißt einer
gesellschaft anzugehören
es fehlt ihnen ein ort das zeigt sich in
den ländern auf unterschiedliche weise
frankreich ist man zb sehr besorgt wegen
der muslimischen bevölkerung im land
nicht einmal so sehr wegen der
emigranten in spanien ist man nicht in
sorge wegen dem islam oder den
immigranten sondern wegen katalonien in
jedem land mache ich also andere
entdeckung ich bilde mich weiter und
sehe wie sich diese identitäts ängste an
unterschiedlichen orten unterschiedlich
auswirken
zum beispiel auch in brasilien eine
multi ethnischen land die frage ist ja
auch warum kommt diese frage nachdem wir
jetzt so sehr auf in so vielen
gesellschaft und das nicht etwas damit
zu tun hat dass die globalisierung uns
mehr und mehr jeden anspricht aus
globale bürger was sie aber irgendwie
auch nie so richtig sein können weil wir
uns doch als lokal verhaftet empfinden
und das stimmt wir können nicht auf
diese weise der welt angehören
die geschichte der modernen demokratie
ist mit den nationalstaat verbunden
wir haben keine beispiele von
demokratien die keine nationalstaaten
sind
warum ist das so ein nationalstaat ist
groß genug um vielen menschen eine
heimat zu bieten aber so klein dass sich
die bewohner mit ihm und der regierung
identifizieren können und sie wissen sie
können an der urne bewirken dass eine
andere partei an die macht kommt europa
tut momentan zwei dinge gleichzeitig
welche die nationalstaaten
auseinanderreißen einerseits die
konstruktion europas von oben herab
andererseits die ungenügende kontrolle
der illegalen einwanderung in allen
europäischen ländern fragen sich die
bürger was müssen wir unternehmen um
diesbezüglich gehört zu werden
in deutschland wird ein gesetz
verabschiedet das von der eu nicht
anerkannt wird
sie wollen ihre grenzen kontrollieren
und die eu hindert sie daran
ich finde deshalb müssen wir uns wieder
auf den nationalstaat konzentrieren was
aber sehr wohl ohne nationalismus
möglich ist man kann auf den vorhandenen
prinzipien und dem bereits existierenden
sozialen kapital aufbauen
damit stellen die sich natürlich
sozusagen eine ganz andere denkt linie
wie viele andere die sagen wir sollten
den nationalstaat abschaffen wir sollten
über noch offene grenzen sprechen aber
das sind wahrscheinlich im moment
wirklich die beiden pole zwischen denen
sich das ganze denken im moment
ansiedelt zentristen
nun es ist interessant und wichtig dass
zb deutschland heute verantwortung für
seine vergangenheit übernimmt das ist
aber nur möglich wenn sich die bewohner
als deutsche definieren können wenn sie
eine deutsche identität haben wenn man
die deutsche identität abschaffen und
alle deutschen europa bürger werden
sollen warum sollten sich diese menschen
dann für die erfahrungen deutschlands
verantwortlich fühlen identität ist
wichtig damit die leute verantwortung
übernehmen für ihre geschichte und diese
dinge stehen nicht im gegensatz
zueinander
dieses wir wie wir ein wir bauen das ist
ihre grundfrage und sie sagen auch kein
gemeinwesen kein staat kann
funktionieren ohne diese idee eines
virus und die sagen dass die
identitätspolitik eigentlich für sie ein
sinnbild habe nämlich das prisma da
bricht das licht ein ist der welt
sozusagen in den regenbogen was ein sehr
sehr schönes bild ist aber sie sagen es
betont eigentlich immer das prisma die
diversität die unterschiedlichen farben
wir sind alle unterschiedliche farben
stattdessen sagen sie vergesst das
prisma oder nimmt es nur sekundär in
erster linie brauchen wir wieder den
handschlag und meine frage war dann was
könnten wir aus gegenstand nehmen was
könnte ich stehen wir den handschlag und
ich habe etwas mitgebrachten würde sie
gerne fragen würde was hier passen die
verfassung der amerikanischen staaten
wäre darf der hammerschlag
das ist ein anfang und es gibt natürlich
eine deutsche idee dazu
so sprach jürgen habermas von
verfassungspatriotismus so ich weiß es
nicht aber ich vermute dass habermas
nicht auf grenzen fokussieren würde denn
man kann verfassungspatriotismus im
verpflichtenden sinne nur pflegen wenn
man sagt wir sind wir
es gibt menschen nicht wir sind mit
denen wollen wir sehr gute beziehungen
pflegt
aber um uns verantwortlich zu fühlen und
uns um andere zu kümmern müssen wir uns
bewusst sein dass wir nicht die anderen
sondern eben wir sind je mehr
immigranten in gewisse europäische
länder strömen desto geringer ist dort
die unterstützung des wohlfahrtsstaates
denn menschen mit anderen ansichten
gelangen ins land und es kommt zu
rassismus
wir brauchen vertrauen soziales
vertrauen
dafür braucht es mehr als nur den
verweis auf ein dokument
wir müssen dieses wir durch einen ort
definieren und durch die ideale die wir
im land schaffen und umzusetzen
versuchen und wie genau schaffen wir das
weil die identitätspolitik hatte ja
schon ein stück weit auch dieses ziel
nenne ich den menschen das gefühl zu
geben gehört zu sein
also wenn man sich anschaut wie groß der
rassismus in den usa zum beispiel ist ja
völlig klar das ist vielen menschen gibt
die sagen ihr könnt noch lange davon
sprechen dass wir amerika sind wir sind
dauernd ausgeschlossen wir sind dauernd
nicht mit gemeint und mir fiel auch noch
technische codes ein der ein buch
geschrieben hat mit dem titel der first
vice präsident natürlich an kramp
adresse gerichtet und er hat ganz klar
gesagt na ja das war nicht das problem
der identitätspolitik oder nicht das
resultat der identitätspolitik sondern
das stichwort ist white supremacy also
weiße vorherrschaft das ist das was die
leute wollten die leute wollten
eigentlich auch sie muss pur von einem
präsidenten verkörpert wie gehen wir
damit um die bauen wie ein wir wenn eine
so große gruppe von menschen sich
dermaßen schlecht behandelt wird und
tatsächlich ja auch oft mit gutem grund
als erstes möchte ich betonen dass ich
dann hazy codes ansicht über unser land
und über die weißen mitbürger keineswegs
teile ehrlich gesagt müsste er mehr
weiße us bürger
lernen aber grundsätzlich haben sie
recht ich sage ihnen wie es
funktionieren könnte
stellen sie sich einen schwarzen
autofahrer vor der ständig von der
polizei angehalten wird in den usa
nennen mir dass analog zur trunkenheit
am steuer schwarz sein am steuer
er ist wütend weil die polizei ihn
anders behandelt als weiße dann stellen
sie sich einen mann vor der in einer
stadt lebt in der es früher eine fabrik
gab er hat seinen job dort verloren er
und seine frau arbeiten teilzeit und
können sich die krankenversicherung für
ihre kinder nicht mehr leisten
dieser mann ist auch wütend wie bringen
wir diese beiden männer zusammen
es geht nicht darum dass sie gegenseitig
ihre ansprüche anerkennen sie müssen
vielmehr überzeugt werden dass es eine
politische partei gibt mit einer vision
des landes die auf gewissen werten
basiert wenn diese werte und prinzipien
umgesetzt werden hilft das beiden
unabhängig von angenommen unsere
grundlegenden prinzipien sind
solidarität und rechtsschutz
dann können wir den schwarzen autofahrer
sagen sie werden laut gesetz ungerecht
behandelt und das werden wir ändern und
dem entlassenen fabrikarbeiter können
wir sagen wir lassen sie nicht im stich
in unserem land gibt es solidarität wir
werden ihnen und ihrer familie helfen
das genügt je mehr wir auf unsere
unterschiede fokussieren desto
schwieriger wird es die aufmerksamkeit
auf etwas anderes zu lenken nämlich auf
die vision des landes dass wir zusammen
aufbauen wollen was sie sagen weil ich
den eindruck habe ich spüre so sehr dass
sie unglaublich vertrauen auf sagen wir
die verfassung auf den rechtsstaat sie
glauben dass man damit die menschen
schützen kann und auch ein wir bauen
aber vorhin haben sie dieses beispiel
gebracht von wo war mit der
abtreibungsdebatte und haben mir
eigentlich gesagt wir haben die
verfassung die sagt abtreibung ist legal
innerhalb einer gewissen frist
und wenn sie eigentlich überzeugen
müssen sind die evangelikalen also das
zeigt auch dass die gesellschaft
irgendwie in einer art und weise
gestrickt
christus selbst wenn sie die gesetze
haben gewisse menschen doch nicht
geschützt sind
das scheint mir normal für die
demokratische politik vor allem in den
usa mit ihrem föderalen system dank dem
die staaten unterschiedliche gesetze
haben können
das problem in einem staat wie oh wahr
ist dass die demokraten nicht präsent
sind
er ist voll und ganz in der hand der
republikanischen partei in den usa
kontrollieren die republikaner zwei
drittel der parlamente der gliedstaaten
und zwei drittel der gouverneurs ämter
in der hälfte der staaten kontrollieren
sie beides wenn sie noch zwei staaten
dazu gewinnen können sie eine
verfassungsgebende versammlung
einberufen
das ist schwer bild.de herr we hope
macht mir das noch viel hoffnung nein
ich denke das einzige was wir tun können
ist es zu versuchen
aber es gibt noch mehr hindernisse als
die von ihnen erwähnten es ist nicht nur
die identitätspolitik es ist auch das
internet die globalisierte wirtschaft
all das splittert unsere gesellschaft um
mit michel houellebecq zu sprechen in
elementarteilchen auf
umso mehr müssen wir etwas finden dass
wir tatsächlich gemeinsam haben und uns
verbindet die tatsache dass wir alle
bürgerinnen und bürger eines landes sind
richtig aber die menschen können sich
nicht der menschheit anschließen und
dinge verändern weil es dafür keine
politische struktur gibt dafür muss man
beim nationalstaat beginnen
das sind wir wieder zurück bei dieser
frage wo ist eigentlich das ideal ist
der ideale raum der nationalstaat oder
der globale zusammenhang um mich hat
sehr interessiert auch ihre analyse wie
es eigentlich zu diesen zuständen
gekommen ist in den usa da liegen sie
nämlich finde ich eine sehr
interessante überlegung vor sie sagen es
gab zwei glaubenssysteme ich versuche
das kurz zusammenzufassen
es gab einerseits erst einmal den new
deal also die ganze roosevelt area 1930
er jahre bis ungefähr 1970 er jahre mit
der bürgerrechtsbewegung und der idee
amerika fußt auf respekt für alle
gleiche aufstiegschancen und ein großes
maß an solidarität
danach kam das glaubenssystem von ron
reagan mit einem minimal start und sehr
sehr viel individualismus auch das was
ihr neoliberalismus nennen und ihre
analyse geht so weit dass sie sagen
eigentlich haben die demokraten da
versagt weil sie denen nichts
entgegenzusetzen haben sie haben die
ganze idee von roosevelt aufgegeben weil
sie den individualismus auch wollten
und dann haben sie sozusagen das ganze
paket eingekauft
warum ist das passiert warum konnte man
diese idee von solidarität was ein stück
weit ja auch immer die gemeinschaft mit
denkt nicht über retten und dann
wirklich bei clinton und obama
verdichten so dass das jetzt die usa
tragen würde
es gibt mehrere gründe
mindestens drei warum sich die
amerikaner von roses ideen abwandeln
zuerst einmal weil vieles von dem was er
wollte erreicht wurde und viele dinge
welche die regierungen den 1960 er und
70 er jahren tat stellten sich als
wirkungslos oder kontraproduktive aus
jede politische epoche oder vision hat
eine halbwertszeit wie uranium sie wirkt
nur eine gewisse zeit
außerdem waren die usa soziologisch ein
individualistischer russland geworden
weiße bürger verließen die ethnisch
durchmischten quartiere in den städten
zogen in die vorstädte und hatten
weniger kindern durch die sexuelle
revolution wurden paare sexuell
unabhängig es gab mehr scheidungen und
alleinerziehende mütter dadurch war viel
vom früheren sozialen kitt verschwunden
wir können individualistischer leben wir
müssen jedoch einen weg finden gewisse
dinge miteinander zu teilen der region
ismus hingegen verstärkte diesen
individualismus politisch und
wirtschaftlich und dann kam die
identitätspolitik die den
individualismus im sinne der
persönlichen identität stärken wollte
seltsamerweise gingen realismus und
identitätspolitik hand in hand
roosevelt hatte eine politische vision
regen eine anti politische vision wegen
der ansicht dass die regierung uns nur
probleme machen dass wir nur eine
minimale regierung bräuchten das die
ideale person die sei die für nichts auf
die regierung angewiesen ist
politik ist demnach suspekt und
gefährlich die identitätspolitik
ihrerseits ist pseudo politisch ihre
vertreter sagen sie seien politisch aber
sie fokussieren nicht auf
institutionelle politik sondern auch
sich selber deshalb braucht es keine
rückkehr
die gibt es nie die ich in meinem
anderen buch aus da unsere gesellschaft
individualistischer geworden ist müssen
wir viel mehr einen weg finden unsere
gemeinsamkeiten zu entdecken und darauf
aufzubauen dass damit wir wieder eine
politische vision des amerikanischen
projekts haben denn amerika ist ein
projekt geschieht dass sie sagen in
ihrem buch ja auch citizens am nordpol
also bürger müssen hier sozusagen
herstellen oder machen oder befähigen
nie machen wir das zuerst mit hilfe von
bildung als ich zur schule ging wurden
wir in staatskunde unterrichtet wir
lernten die amerikanische geschichte
kennen und dieses buch hier die
verfassung
das wird in den heutigen schulen kaum
noch gelehrt
es gibt zwar bürger kunde unterricht
aber dabei geht es um sozialen
aktivismus nicht um institutionelle
macht die es jedoch braucht ist
denn als die generation der 1960 er
jahre die universitäten und straßen
verließ und die neue linke zusammenbrach
wurden ihre vertreter lehrer an
gymnasien und schulen und brachten die
bewegungs und identitätspolitik dort ein
wichtig ist womit unsere kinder heute
aufwachsen
es beginnt also bei der erziehung wir
brauchen zudem eine führungsperson die
das verkörpert da es nicht vorhersehbar
ist wann so eine persönlichkeit
auftaucht müssen wir eine botschaft
bereit halten
und sobald diese person auftaucht kann
sie zusammen mit der botschaft ein
beispiel für die ganze nation sein
es ist interessant wenn sie zurückgehen
in den 1950 er jahre sagten
kommentatoren damals über amerikanische
kinder
sie seien unpolitisch und einzig daran
interessiert vorwärts zu kommen und geld
zu verdienen und dann kommt john f
kennedy und sagt den satz den sie
erwähnt haben frage nicht was dein land
für dich tun kann sondern was du für
dein land tun kannst diese einerseits
elektrisierte eine ganze generation
das gibt mir hoffnung es wird der moment
kommen in dem etwas die jungen menschen
entfacht etwas das sie nicht nur
verstehen lässt was unser projekt ist
sondern auch was ihre pflichten sind und
ihnen verantwortungsgefühl für andere
vermittelt zum anfang des gesprächs
dieser satz nach amerika gray denn ich
glaube es ist sehr deutlich geworden
dass sie trumps wahlspruch so nicht
unterschreiben aber vor allem auch seine
politik nicht unterschreiben
aber man könnte ja sagen ein stück
dessen was sie beschreiben möchte er ja
auch er möchte auch ein starkes amerika
bauen
inwiefern ist ihre vision anders wie die
vision von donald trump zuerst einmal
wäre es ein land das nicht da
angst gründet auf der angst vor der
gegenwart und auch nicht auf
ressentiments anstatt sündenböcke für
die heutige situation zu suchen würde
man hoffnungsvoll auf die ressourcen
fokussieren die wir haben und die unser
land einen können
ich sehe trump als übergangs figuren wie
andere präsidenten steht her zwischen
zwei großen epochen aber trump ist eine
zutiefst reaktionäre persönlichkeit denn
etwas haben alle reaktionären menschen
gemeinsam sie sehen den bruch in der
geschichte als werk einer kleinen gruppe
von menschen und es sind immer dieselben
professoren journalisten denker künstler
lehrer manchmal ganz allgemein die juden
tram hat diese mentalität und da wir
radikal konservative medien haben
beginnend mit fox news ist es möglich
die wut der menschen innerhalb dieser
blase zu spüren
sie ärgern sich über das was sie als
intrige der liberalen elite an den
beiden küsten empfinden und sie werden
von ihrem hass und ihren ängsten anstatt
von ihren hoffnungen angetrieben
die ganze frage wie es eigentlich weiter
geht in den usa die wird ja im nächsten
winter auch noch einmal richtig
interessant wenn die midterm elections
sind am 6 november und für mich ist
interessant dass ich den eindruck habe
noch vor ein paar monaten hatte man den
eindruck das wird nie und nimmer so sein
dass der kongress kippen könnte also
dass trump die mehrheit verlieren könnte
plötzlich sieht es doch wieder ein stück
weit anders aus das wechselt immer mal
wieder aber insgesamt muss man doch
klarerweise sagen die haben glaube ich
donald trump gehörig unterschätzt die
meisten in europa dachten dass eine
komplette witzfigur sei es gab
unglaublich viel verballhornung und
seiner figur
insgesamt muss man sagen die wirtschaft
in den usa die bruins
bevor man von den nächsten wahlen
spricht muss man sagen einerseits ist
trump an äußerst unberechenbarer mann
der von heute auf morgen etwas tun
könnte dass ihnen die wahlen gewinnen
oder verlieren lässt andererseits wird
mehrfach gegen ihn ermittelt was die
ausgangslage verändern könnte und dann
gibt es noch etwas das sie angedeutet
haben wir haben job unterschätzt weil
wählerumfragen nicht mehr vorhersagen
wie die leute dann tatsächlich wählen
sie erzählen einem interview etwas und
tun dann das gegenteil
das muss man berücksichtigen es gibt
gute und schlechte vorzeichen gut ist
dass es mehr mögliche demokratischen
präsidentschaftskandidaten gibt als die
demokratische partei unterstützen kann
es gibt inzwischen organisationen die
kandidaten instruieren wie man einen
wahlkampf sie schienen videos die ihnen
zeigen wie man geld beschafft und
richtig einsetzt und wie man mit den
medien umgeht
zudem sind viele kandidaten
kriegsveteranen
ich habe mit einigen gesprochen es gibt
irak und afghanistan veteranen die
zurückgekommen sind die demokraten sind
wenn wir solche demokraten haben also
nicht nur hippies und professoren die
eine gerechtere gesellschaft aufbauen
möchten könnte uns das wirklich helfen
die kehrseite ist dass sich alle darauf
konzentrieren trump und den tramp ismus
zu bekämpfen
das funktioniert nur solange tromp da
ist das ist nicht von dauer
und worauf die demokraten allergisch
sind ist langfristiges nachdenken über
ihre botschaft über das wofür sie
einstehen
als ich das buch schrieb ging ich auf
die webseite der republikanischen partei
man findet eine liste mit elf prinzipien
für welche die republikaner einstehen
die verfassung ist das erste emigration
das letzte sehr klar auf der webseite
der demokraten findet man nichts
dergleichen aber 17 links zu
verschiedenen minderheits gruppen
die demokraten müssen aufhören sich als
vertreter von minderheiten zu verstehen
sondern müssen über eine langfristige
botschaft nachdenken wieder bei dieser
klientel politik die sie so kritisieren
wagen sie dennoch eine prognose für den
november
aus allen diesen gründen ist es
schwierig es würde mich nicht
überraschen wenn wir in den vorwahlen im
november gut abschneiden würden aber das
ist weil wir niemandem gegen trump
aufstehen müssen im jahr 2020 müssen
sich die demokraten genau überlegen
welche personen mit welcher politik
gegen jump antreten wird falls er wieder
kandidieren
gut möglich dass sie es vermasselt
trumps ehemaliger chef stratege steve
bennett gab ein interview
weswegen er gefeuert oder darin ging es
unter anderem um identitätspolitik er
sagte solange die demokraten über rasse
und identität sprechen schlagen wie sie
von diesen themen können wir immer
profitieren
das problem ist die demokraten haben
steve spannen jeden tag zu gedient das
muss aufhören
wir müssen einen kandidaten aufstellen
mit einer größeren vision dem es nicht
um einzelne gruppen geht der es mit
trump aufnehmen kann etwas was uns
natürlich in europa sehr beschäftigt in
der schweiz auch diskutiert wird ist die
frage wie der handelsstreit ausgehen
wird und da hat ja trump eine marke
gesetzt könnte man jetzt neutral sagen
in dem er eigentlich handelszölle jetzt
erheben will gegen die gegen das wto
recht verstoßen
interessant daran mal ganz unabhängig
davon was da die rechtliche situation
ist und wie man das einschätzen mag
interessant daran fand ich dass ich mich
erinnert fühlt dann ein gespräch mit
sahra wagenknecht der abgeordneten der
linken die als linke gesagt hat was wir
wieder lernen müssen ist einzusehen dass
die globale wirtschaft eben diese dieses
lokale zugehörigkeitsgefühl
red und wir müssen wieder mehr
eigentlich protektionismus einführen und
das ist das was jetzt eigentlich donald
trump tut also etwas von dem auch was ja
ein stück weit vielleicht mit meinen
wenn sie sagen wir müssen wieder den
nationalstaat stärken
bezüglich der handelspolitik sind donald
trump und bernie sanders gleicher
meinung es gibt eine linke und eine
rechte position im kampf gegen die
globalisierung
ja das war eines der dinge die ponys
enders vorantrieb wir müssen die nafta
loswerden wir müssen viele unserer
handelsvereinbarungen loswerden und sie
neu verhandeln
da sind sich die beiden einig unter
anderem weil niemand weiß wie man sich
gegenüber der wirtschaftlichen
globalisierung verhalten soll
das müssen wir zuerst einmal zu geben
niemand von der rechten oder linken weiß
was zu tun ist keiner hat einen geheimen
plan in der tasche aber politiker müssen
wahlen gewinnen indem sie vorgeben eine
lösung zu haben
bezüglich der wirtschaftlichen
globalisierung in so einer situation
kann man gewinnen wenn man als
unverantwortlicher demagoge auftritt
wäre bernie sanders gewählt worden wären
viele dinge heute in unserem land völlig
anders aber ich denke die handelspolitik
wäre dieselbe wenn ich auf unser
gespräch zurückblicke möchte ich noch
einmal zurückkommen auf houellebecq und
die idee der elementarteilchen das ist
ein buch was sie immer wieder zitieren
ich glaube der begriff gefällt ihnen
sehr sie sagen ein problem ist dass wir
ein stück weit in der gleich kann man
sagen neoliberalen welt aber eben auch
in der liberalen welt elementarteilchen
geworden sind und die gesellschaft oder
mehr die gemeinschaft ein stück weit aus
dem blick verloren haben
was könnten sie vielleicht noch so als
philosophischen idee auf gegen programm
anbieten
ritsche ratsche zb taucht auch immer
wieder auf der amerikanische philosoph
dessen kleines büchlein archiv in aber
country jetzt auch nach der wahl von
kramp immer wieder zitiert worden
er liebäugelt ja so ein bisschen mit
einer mit einem neuen roosevelt
patriotismus können sie dazu noch ein
paar dinge sagen was ist ihre
persönliche vision in welche richtung
soll sich den amerika entwickeln
ich glaube es war adam michnik der nach
dem mauerfall als polen unabhängig wurde
sagte im kommunismus nahmen sie das
wunderschöne aquarium der polnischen
gesellschaft und machten daraus fisch so
wird unser job ist es aus der fischsuppe
wieder ein aquarium zu das ist natürlich
nicht möglich wenn man nur noch einzelne
teilchen hat ist es eine fantasie zu
glauben man könne daraus wieder ein
ganzes herstellen
die konservativen haben diesbezüglich
recht soziale bande kann man nicht
bewusst bilden
sie entwickeln sich man kann einzig
versuchen nichts zu tun was die bande
zerstören könnte die es bereits aber ich
denke wir werden in einer welt mit
weniger starken sozialen bindungen leben
das ist eine tatsache in der
gesellschaft in der gemeinschaft doch in
der politik hat man die möglichkeit zu
sagen wie unterschiedlich sie auch sein
mögen weil wir als bürger dinge teilen
können wir uns für ein projekt
engagieren dank dessen es uns in allen
diesen belangen besser geht ohne dass
man zum beispiel gemeinsam essen oder
sich oft treffen müsste oskar weis sagte
das problem mit dem sozialismus ist dass
er zu viele abend gefordert
diese art von gesellschaft gibt es nicht
mehr deshalb müssen wir unsere
gesellschaft anpassen aber die
politische vision eines bürger
bewusstseins in nationalstaaten haben
denn dann haben wir die größte chance
die menschen zusammenzubringen
ein bisschen die des
verfassungspatriotismus von habermas den
sie erwähnt haben um viele sagen ja das
ist eine sehr kalte technokratische idee
aber vielleicht teilen wir beide das
dass mich das eigentlich immer auch
überzeugt hat dies die die vernünftige
einsicht darin dass man mit einem
hirnschlag oder mit einer verfassung
gemeinsam entscheiden kann wie wollen
die zusammenleben und welche
aufstiegschancen sollen alle haben
welche rechte sollen alle haben das ist
ja schon mal eigentlich nicht schlecht
sich darauf einigen zu können
ja aber ich glaube nicht dass es auch
vernunft basiert wie sie oder habermas
vorschlagen
wir müssen verstehen was für wesen wir
sind zuerst einmal gibt es sehr viele
unvernünftige überlastete und
ungebildete menschen wie kann man mit
ihnen einen nationalstaat bilden
anhand von symbolen mittels rhetorik und
in dem man über die geschichte spricht
dabei darf man vor allem nicht nur auf
negative geschehnisse verweisen
man muss von positiven ereignissen
berichten auf welche die leute stolz
sein können und die sie zusammen
schweißen
man muss die ganze säle nicht nur den
verstand einbeziehen was habermas
verdächtig fand und man muss mit grenzen
leben können
aber wenn die fahne gehisst wird sollen
die menschen in den usa etwas empfinden
deshalb gibt es heute diese kontroversen
wegen sport stars die sich beim
erklingen der nationalhymnen nicht
erheben
wir haben die tradition dass vor allen
sportanlässen die nationalhymne gespielt
wird und da gibt es sport stars die auf
die knie gehen um für alle möglichen
anliegen zu demonstrieren wie etwa black
lips matter die arbeit die menschen
sollen fühlen das sind wir
egal wie wir aussehen oder woher unsere
familien stammen
wir werden nicht nur durch unsere
verfassung zusammen gehalten die diese
fahne repräsentiert sondern auch durch
menschen die für diese fahne gestorben
sind oder jeden tag ihres lebens für den
dienst an diesem land opfern die
einsicht dass sind wir braucht da so
vielleicht vernunft braucht emotionen
ist braucht geschichten und vielleicht
auch eine gemeinsame kultur
das danke ihnen sehr dieses gespräch war
habe ich danke ihnen
nächste woche wird hier didaktisch
natürlich mit einem schuss philosophie
ich weiß hat fragt die philosophie nina
schmitz wie wir gute freunde werden
können für andere und für uns selbst
und jetzt gleich geht es um einen
musiker der das beinahe unmögliche
geschafft hat nämlich mit jazz hallen zu
füllen wie ein popstar
elf teams wenzel war ein phänomen aber
sehen sie jetzt eine gute zeit bis bald
[Musik]